you know like we got a lot of comments
that were like why does conor think
americans are like another species it's
because you are
there's so many things to me that is
like a british person i'm just so
baffled by when americans explain it to
me and
yeah there's just so many things i'm
just like what america we're going to
offend so many people with this [ __ ]
america is another i love americans but
there's just like just general life
stuff there's
like what what every time i go to
america i'm like this is another planet
like i i can't relate to these okay on a
side note there's also so many [ __ ]
things i love about america
yeah oh yeah of course of course like
i'm not gonna be like i'm never gonna go
back to america of course i love america
i think i've never had like met
friendlier people than in america like
i love the uk it's my home but damn are
people [ __ ] depressed oh yeah yeah
dude i get the best elevator experience
in america no exactly you feel
so [ __ ] happy right you're talking to
americans and i'm like
man maybe maybe they're on to something
yeah and like we clown on their food but
damn
man some places they give you some
[ __ ] amazing oh dude like i'll clan
on their food but if
someone was like you want a philly
cheesesteak i'm like hell yeah whatever
cheesesteak you want to go chick-fil-a
yeah yeah of course i do like five guys
of course
oh my god five guys bro i [ __ ] love
five guys
drawing my body has never felt so
[ __ ] good
five guys man the best ex the best way
to experience five guys
is that like three a.m you're absolutely
hammered from the booze and you're like
i need something in my stomach oh five
guys
i really go to five guys you got the
greasiest [ __ ] burger and while
you're eating it it's like
it's it's it's like cajun fries man it's
the cajun cajun fries as well it's cajun
fries but also the burger just the
combination of those two is like the
best [ __ ] thing in the world but i've
never experienced like
life and death at the same time while
eating something you know what i mean
it's like
it's like experience i'm like oh god i
feel i'm so glad i'm alive but then the
moment it goes down myself because i'm
like [ __ ] i want to die right now
holy [ __ ] i really want to do a like a
road
trip around the u.s because like it's
yeah it seems like there's so many like
diverse cultures and cool [ __ ] they get
up to every time i go to a new state i
always go
i always try and go to like a fast food
chain that's like specific to
that state just because it's so
different like i know you guys don't
like in and out but i [ __ ] love it
now
it's not that i don't like it i just
think it's a bit overrated i've never
had it it's a bit overhyped but
it's just like it's good but it's not
something like froth dude i [ __ ] over
i love it dude whenever like i go to la
and if evan picks me up i'm like evan
let's go in now right now i want to go
in and out right now you know what's a
really good burger chain in texas they
have this burger chain called
whataburger
yeah they've oh i've heard about have
them in california as well they didn't
know
yeah but it was like originally
interesting like whataburger is like
[ __ ] awesome like the spicy sauce
that they have is
so good yeah like i feel like i'm dying
but every single day
i feel so happy with the food i've eaten
in america yeah but then i guess
that would wear off if i lived there
every day i think so yeah maybe
i i just feel so happy in the u.s i'm
like the food's amazing everyone's so
kind
the hotels are so spacious in london you
pay like 200
for like a closet yeah if you're lucky
you might have your own toilet like the
hotel game in england is just weak
it's the shittest thing on earth it's
like the business hotels here right it's
like would you like a bed and a hallway
200 please if you want a semi-competent
hotel in london you've got to pay like
300 pounds or maybe 200 pounds if you
get lucky and find a good way but in
america
every single hotel i've been to except
i've never been to a motel so i don't
[ __ ] with those
yeah because that's why people die in
films
i've had an amazing hotel experience
that's why fugitives like hide out
right yeah everything every single thing
that's bad happens near a motel so i've
just
my brain has been taught don't go to a
motel calling a motel a hotel is the
equivalent of calling mcdonald's a
restaurant right
it's like no it's not